I thought it's a bit of fun we could
extend what we've done already you don't
have to watch the videos you might want
to go back and watch the previous videos
later on we certainly here in Western
Europe when we utter a sentence tend to
be happy with subject-verb-object order
the man goes to town it's really quite
common across a lot of languages what
we've done is put together a vocabulary
with lots of silly things in it like the
dog the man the robot for the subject
bit cake strokes for the verb and the
object of course is the the thing that
these actions are done on so you can
have the robot kick the dog whatever you
like but then we got to thinking subject
verb object
is this favored by all beings in the
universe are there some beings out there
the regardless of the actual details of
language in the words be a finishing Lee
French Spanish don't like
subject-verb-object orderings they'd
like to do it's a weird way around
how about object subject verb so instead
of saying the man goes to town as we
would say to town the man goes sounded
to me 20 years ago I first stumbled on
this very much like Yoda the Jedi Master
for those of you coming into this cold
and direct because you saw the word
Yoder and grep over the entire universe
for what this could possibly mean you
landed back here in Nottingham and
you're finding that we've done a Yoda
syntax transformer we started off by
doing the theory grammar and been able
to make up sentences like the robot
stroked two furry dice but we didn't do
anything with it all we did in those
early ones but there are details there
you might find it interesting to say how
is it decided that the robot stroked to
furry dice is in some sense we the eagle
and okay because that's what we've done
we're basically saying it's okay usable
for use Row three user oh six so we were
sitting there struggling
what would be what you typically doing a
compiler we've analyzed what's wanted in
a compiler you generate code so what's
our code generation cuz we're not doing
anything at the moment our code
generation is gonna be so simple it's
gonna be take the subject-verb-object
parse tree as it's called for the input
sentence swap around the object to the
front leave the subject in the middle
and the verb at the end so it's quite a
good exercise on how to hang your
actions off what's called a yak grammar
that implements this and I think you
might actually enjoy that so just for a
bit of fun in this limited vocabulary of
words we've got what we're gonna do is
analyze the input and say have you
really put this in in subject verb or
object boring order and if you have done
that correctly then as the action of our
parser we will Yoda rise it we will turn
it into Yoda order and put it out that
way I just wish we had a speech
synthesizer in here Shawn bring one with
you next time so that we could speak it
but let's see I have got a compiled up
program to do all of this it is called
Yola it's waiting for input the standard
sentence the one we like best of all in
this silly graph we've put together is
the robot stroked to furry dice so that
shall be our first test basin oh look
that not only has it analyzed for me
which rules in the grammar were used to
analyze our subject-verb-object centers
and to be happy that it is in SVO order
that's a necessary starting point but
then the transformation the action of
our brilliant yoda compiler if you like
is Yoda says to ferry dice the robot
stroke so in other words we have picked
out from the input centers what the
object bill was at the end which
promoted that to the front then we've
left the subject
the next piece after that and the verb
comes in last to Fermi dosa robot stroke
God ask me another one sure let's see if
it works well let's go for a very clear
simple wondered dog bit them and the dog
is man happy with the analysis look
slightly different to last time but if
this still subject-verb-object Yoda
would say the man the dog a bit I think
that works don't you Shan you do you've
always got to say well even in that
reordering is it clear who's getting
bitten yeah we're very clear that that
is a subject that it is the dog biting
the man still yes because this grammar
has this one cute phrase of stroke Tooth
Fairy dies have Fred I've called the
whole grammar furry but this is Yoda
rised phorus beat now maybe we need
people to contribute to this and expand
its recovery we're putting out a zip
file full of all of the Lex and yak
files that make this up some of you
could try out we rerun the whole thing
if you've got Linux systems basically
even for those of you that haven't I'm
also including the in speed you can
complete C program file that those pre
processes generate so you could always
come in in the middle try compiling the
C file it will probably be ok don't get
frustrated by missing libraries if
you're on UNIX or Linux you should be ok
if you follow the instructions for those
of you brave souls running C on either
Windows or Macintosh I've been out on
the web and looked up and you can get it
to work but what happens is people
translate the tools but forget about the
libraries but nevermind let's see where
we get to and I hope you all have a lot
of fun with us I've even included the
binaries for 64-bit intel based Linux a
as some of you may even be able to just
execute those just that I don't know but
many of you might want to recompile the
C and hopefully if the library of there
you know you may be able to get the
whole thing working again once you're
succeeding in getting the basic thing
going you may want to have a lot of fun
making Yoda's vocabulary much more Star
Wars related I've come off the furry
grandma that I was already doing just as
a bit of a silly very elementary
exercise but no you could you could fill
up your vocab strings with Jedi
lightsaber Death Star all this kind of
stuff sean has just pointed out to me
they're not called robots in Star Wars
are called drawings is that right so you
can translate the word robot into droid
or you could even come backwards you
know if you'll just speak you give we
want it back assess vo subject verb oh
yeah so back from Yoda ordering back
into English ordering will be another
thing to do translator translator yeah
if I go from London and then subtract
England and then add I don't know Japan
we'd hope for Tokyo we'd hope for Tokyo
and we get Tokyo we got Tokyo twice
weirdly